--solutions for problem set 8.
I found some problems
as I went through them.
These are all new because we've
never been in this territory
before this early where we
could actually offer problems.
So it's a little
bit of a shakedown.
8.2, simply, I don't think
you have enough background
to actually do it.
If you want to try
it, be my guest.
I'll give you a sketch
of a solution, anyway.
But really, for the
same reason that I
didn't do exercise
3 in Chapter 11,
we really shouldn't have
done exercise 2, either.
For 8.3, which is
a decoding exercise
using the BCJR algorithm.
I don't know if we'll get
to the BCJR algorithm today.
If we do, then please do it.
If we don't, then
we can defer it.
And you also need to know
that the noise variance is 1.
Or, pick something,
but I suggest
you just pick sigma
squared equals 1,
even though that's
a large value.
OK, any questions?
Has anyone tried to
do the homework yet?
Not yet.
Good strategy.
OK, Chapter 11.
We have one topic to go in
Chapter 11, which is just
the last little bit on Hadamard
transform realizations, which
I do want to cover.
We've really been talking
about styles of realizations
on codes on graphs,
graphical realizations.
We had the generator.
And we had the parity check
and we had the trellis-style.
And we even had a
tail-biting trellis.
And we also developed
the cut-set bound
which doesn't exactly
prove, but strongly suggests
that we're going
to need cycles in
our graphical representations.
And one reason I want to
talk about the Hadamard
transform realizations,
the Reed-Muller codes,
is that they really demonstrate
this point I think very nicely.
If we allow cycles, we get
very simple representations.
If we demand
cycle-free, then we get
still pretty nice realizations,
but much more complicated.
They meet the cut-set
bound everywhere.
Reed-Muller codes in general
are pretty good anyway
for trellis realizations,
but they're certainly
much more complicated than
the realizations with cycles.
So that's what we're
going to do today
is-- at least the first part is
Hadamard transform realizations
of Reed-Muller codes.
OK, what's the Hadamard
transform over the binary field
F2?
It's related to but
a little different
than the Hadamard transform
over the real field.
So people seeing the latter,
you'll see similarities,
but you may see
differences as well.
So the Hadamard transform.
I think you remember when we
defined Reed-Muller codes, one
of the ways we defined them was
in terms of a universal matrix
Um, which I defined as
the m-fold tensor product,
very briefly written like
that, of a 2 by 2 matrix, u1.
What does u1 look like?
u1 looks like-- over the binary
field, it just looks like this.
It's the set of generators for
the Reed-Muller codes of length
2.
What you would expect, it's
a lower triangular matrix.
And if we want to
take-- I don't know
if you've run into
tensor products before.
If we want to take the 2 by
2 tensor product like that,
we simply replace each one by
the matrix itself and each 0
by a matrix of 0's.
So we get a 4 by 4 matrix which
looks like this 1, 0, 1, 1, 1,
0, 1, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0.
And what do you know?
That's what we called our
universal Reed-Muller generator
matrix for m equals 2.
In other words, for
Reed-Muller codes of length 4.
And you see how all
the Reed-Muller codes
are generated.
We can find generators for
all the Reed-Muller codes
from this set.
And similarly, u3
was this matrix
that we've now seen many times.
So all these matrices
have common properties.
They're all lower triangular.
They have many properties.
One of them is that all
of them are self-inverse.
And that's very easy
to prove from the fact
that u1 is clearly self-inverse.
u1 times u1 is the
identity matrix.
And because these are
all tensor products,
that makes all of these
their own inverses.
So what's the 2 to the m by 2
to the m Hadamard transform is
if we have a vector
u, then u times u m,
a vector y is called the
Hadamard transform of u.
What's the inverse Hadamard
transform if you like?
Well, since u m is
its own inverse,
if we just multiply both sides
by u, we get u equals y u m.
So to get u back, we just
transform y again by u m.
So the inverse
Hadamard transform
is the Hadamard transform
again in this case.
So we get the typical kind
of transform relationship.
You can think of this time
domain, frequency domain.
Anyway, this is the
set of variables
from which we can get
this set of variables.
They're somehow in dual domains.
OK.
Well, now recall one definition
of the Reed-Muller codes.
The Reed-Muller codes
are-- Rm of mr is-- sorry,
it's always rm, which I've
always found curious notation.
Since m is more
important than r,
it would seem that
you would say m first,
but maybe it was for
this, I don't know.
This is generated by--
so let's say that.
The rows of u m of
weight 2 to the m minus r
[? for ?] greater.
So for instance, the 0 order
Reed-Muller code of length 8
is simply the 8, 1, 8
repetition code and it's
generated by this last row.
It's the only one of weight 8.
If we want the
Reed-Muller code of length
8 and minimum distance 4,
we take this, this, this,
and this as our
four generator rows
and we get the 8,
4, 4 code that we've
been mostly using for examples.
If we want the
single parity check
code of length 8,
the 8, 7, 2 code,
we take all these 7
generators, everyone
except for the unique
weight 1 generator up here.
And as a hint for
doing the homework,
it's helpful to notice
that if we write
the indices of these rows
as 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
then notice there's
a relationship
between the Hamming
weight of the m bit binary
expansion of these indices
and the weights of these rows.
Is that clear instantly?
I won't prove it, but if
the Hamming weight is 3,
then the row has weight 8.
If the Hamming weight is 2,
then the row has weight 4.
If the hamming weight is 1,
then the row has weight 2.
And if the hamming weight is
0, then the row has weight 1.
And that's the easiest way
I've found to do problem 8.1.
So these-- there are infinity
of relations, nice relations,
you could prove
for these things.
They're very important
combinatorially and so forth.
OK, so from this
observation, we can therefore
define a Reed-Muller code as
the set of all u times u m
where we simply let some of
the ui free for some rows.
In other words, it's
just a binary variable.
And 0 for other rows as I just
described in words over here.
So basically, where
we're going is
we're going to define some kind
of graph which realizes u m.
We're going to put the
8-- do it either way.
I'm going to put
y0 y7 over here.
If we're doing a code of
length 8, I'll put u3 in here.
We're going to have 8 other
things sticking out over here.
I shouldn't draw these
because they're really
going to be internal,
implicit variables.
So this will be u0
through u7 in some order.
It turns out to be necessary
to play with the order
to get a nice-looking graph.
And we're going to fix
some of these to 0.
For instance, for
the 8, 4, 4 code,
we're going to fix those to 0.
And we're going to allow these
coefficients corresponding
to rows of weight 4 or
more be free arbitrary
binary variables.
So the set of all
code words will
be generated as the
set of all Hadamard
transforms of 8 tuples, which
are fixed to 0 in these 4
positions, and which are
free in these 4 positions.
Is that clearly stated?
I think I'm reasonably
proud of that.
So that's what I mean
by this notation here.
And it's clear that the
dimension of the code
is the number of free
coefficients here.
Basically, because the u
m matrix is invertible,
so we're going to
get an isomorphism
between 4 tuples and code words.
So that's a way of
constructing Reed-Muller codes.
Now, how do I get a nice
graphical representation
of u m?
Let's work on that for
the next little bit.
Well, as always with
Reed-Muller codes,
we should do things recursively.
We should start with u1.
That's a pretty
simple relationship.
How do we draw a graph for the
relationship y equals u1 u?
OK, that means y0 equals u0.
Let's see.
Is that right?
I've been putting
u on the left here
to imitate what we do
with generator matrices.
So that equation is
y0, y1 equals u0, u1.
Sometimes I have problems
with basic things like this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
want row vectors.
Sorry.
OK, so that's the
equation, which
we can see that says y0 equals
u0 and y1 equals u0 plus u1.
Do I agree with that?
y1 equals-- no, still not right.
AUDIENCE: y0 is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Plus u1.
And y2 is-- y1 is u1.
All right.
Sorry, now we're in business.
OK, so let's draw a
little graph of that.
We have y1 equals u1.
And if I make an
equals down here,
I'll get a little u1 in here.
So I can put u0 in here and
get out y0 equals u0 plus u1.
OK, so that's a
graphical realization
of this Hadamard transform.
If I put 2 bits in
here for u, then
I'll get the Hadamard
transform out here for y.
But by the way, notice there
aren't any arrows here.
This is a behavioral
realization.
And I could equally
well put a 2 tuple here
on the y's and I'd get out the
Hadamard transform at the u's.
It goes either way.
And this I find
somewhat interesting
is called a controlled NOT gate.
The idea here is that this
bottom variable is the control
and it determines whether
this variable is inverted
or not as it goes across here.
And this is a basic gate
in quantum mechanics.
Maybe the basic gate in quantum
mechanical realizations.
[INAUDIBLE] at least
[INAUDIBLE] cubits.
But anyway, that's actually
neither here nor there.
All right, so that's
how we realize u1.
All right, now
recursively there must
be some way of putting together
little blocks like this
to make bigger
blocks, say, for u2.
To realize u2 or u3.
OK, so for u2, let me just
try to steam ahead and hope
this will work.
We build another gate to
do a set of transforms
to an intermediate
variable here.
Intermediate variables, and
then we sort of do a butterfly.
We're going to build this out
of 4 little blocks like this.
We're going to write like this.
And how are we going
to tie them together?
The outputs here are going
to go to the equals signs.
to go to the plus signs.
And we get something that
looks like that for the 2
by 2 Hadamard transform.
And y0, y1, y2, y3.
Now, probably this
should be u2 and this
should be u1 just from
the way these works.
And if we do that, we get what?
This is u3.
This is u1 plus u3.
This is u2.
This u0 plus u2.
So we get that--
doing it backwards,
y3 equals u3, y2 equals u2
plus u3, y1 equals u1 plus u3,
and y0 equals u0 plus
u2 plus u1 plus u3.
And that's probably correct,
but it's something like that.
Done in the notes.
And those of you who have ever
looked at the fast Fourier
transform will see
some resemblance here
to the butterflies that occur
in a fast Fourier transform.
And it's not surprising
because these are all
based on groups of-- in
this case, z2 squared.
And so they have the
same algebraic structure
underlying them.
But that's, again,
a side comment
that I won't take
time to justify.
And similarly for
8, if we want to do
the 8-- there's a
picture in the notes--
we build 8 of these gates.
Maybe I actually have
to do it because I
want to reduce it also.
So 1, 2, 3, 4.
Sorry, this takes a little time.
This is where making up slides
ahead of time is a good idea.
All right, so we have
three levels of 2 by 2
Hadamard transforms
as you might expect.
At each level, we do four
2 by 2 Hadamard transforms.
And we connect them together.
At the first level, we
stay within the half.
We connect them together
in the same way.
And at the next level,
we have to spread out
over the whole
thing, so we get--
this goes up to this equals.
This goes up to this equals.
This goes up to that equals.
This comes down here.
This comes down here
and this goes across.
That gives y0, y1,
y2, and so forth.
y3, y4, y5, y6, y7.
And again, we have to
jigger with the order here.
Probably something like this.
OK, in any case, it's done
correctly in the notes.
All right, so this executes
an 8 by 8 Hadamard transform.
You put y's on here and you
get the Hadamard transform
out on the u's, or vice versa.
You with me?
OK.
Notice that the components
here are all very simple.
I've got a graphical realization
of the Hadamard transform
relationship that involves only
binary variables, first of all.
All the internal variables
here are just bits.
They're all binary.
And all of the constraint nodes
are these simple little degree
3 constraint nodes.
The only two nontrivial ones
you will probably ever see.
Namely, the zero
sum type of node
and the equality type of node.
3, 2, 2 and 3, 1, 1 if we
consider them as codes.
So it's made up of
extremely simple elements.
And in that sense, we can say
it's a simple randomization.
But of course, this
graph is full of cycles,
isn't that right?
Yes.
These little things
cause cycles.
So we get cycles as we go
around like that, for instance.
Nonetheless, it's a perfectly--
you put something over here
and you get something
deterministic out over here.
All right.
So to realize the 8, 4, 4 code--
are you all with me on this?
I should check again.
Is there anybody who
doesn't understand this?
That's always the way
to put the question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You count the output
when you're counting degree?
PROFESSOR: Do I count the
output when I'm counting degree?
In this case, yes.
I reserve my options on that.
Sometimes I do,
sometimes I don't.
It's whatever is convenient.
My choice.
Sorry, I think I just
whacked the microphone.
OK.
So now, let me go to
my Reed-Muller code
realization, the 8, 4, 4 code.
How are we going
to realize that?
We've got these internal
variables here, some of which
we're going to hold to 0.
These four we're
going to hold to 0.
And the rest we're
going to let go free.
And so I claim
that already now I
have a realization of the 8,
4, 4 code, if I regard these
as internal variables, these
as my external variables
over here.
OK, does everyone find
that plausible at least?
OK.
But having done that--
now, watch this part
closely because this
part you're going
to have to imitate
on the homework.
We can do some reductions.
All right.
If I have a 2 by 2
Hadamard transform of 0, 0,
what's the result?
0, 0.
OK.
I can do that in several steps,
but that's a good way to do it.
So I don't really
need these gates here.
I can just put 0's over here.
Similarly, down here if I have
a 2 by 2 Hadamard transform of 2
free variables, internal
variables, what do I get?
I get two free variables.
One of them happens to be
u3 plus u7 and the other one
is just u7.
I could call this
u3 prime, let's say.
And since it's an
internal variable
that I'm just using
to generate the code,
I can delete that, too.
So what can I do
about these here?
When I have one free
variable and one zero,
what's going to happen?
This free variable is going
to come through here and here.
The 0 doesn't count
here, so a plus just
becomes a repetition in effect.
It's got to have the same
parity as this input,
so it is that input.
So by another major
sweep, I'll just--
this is an internal variable.
I'll just call this u6.
OK, I don't need to actually
draw a gate to generate it.
It has to be the
same here and here,
so I have to tie it together.
Similarly, down here I
can just call this u5.
And now, continuing
in here-- I hope this
is going to come out all right.
It doesn't seem
quite right so far,
but let's see how it comes out.
What do we have coming in here?
We have two different
free variables.
So again, let me just
call this u3 prime again.
And this is maybe u5 prime.
But in any case, I
can just draw this.
In this case, I'm
coming around this way.
And u3 prime was
dangling anyway,
so I can leave that over here.
And similarly down here,
I get two free ones,
so let me just call
them like this.
And this is equal to y7.
Well, it's a little strange.
I did something wrong there.
I did something wrong.
Well, maybe not.
Maybe not.
This is not going the way
it's gone in the past,
so maybe I drew the graph
differently in the first place.
This is u6 again.
This is still u6 up here.
But this is a 0.
So this is u6 also
coming out here.
But I need this
little-- I do need
to replicate u6 three times.
And maybe that's what
I needed down here too,
was to replicate u5 three times.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The bottom line.
PROFESSOR: Say again,
I just didn't hear it.
AUDIENCE: The bottom line.
You remove that
[INAUDIBLE] shortcut.
PROFESSOR: I removed--
this equaled a shortcut.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There was an
[INAUDIBLE] on top of it,
right.
And--
AUDIENCE: That
cannot be replaced.
PROFESSOR: That cannot be
replaced by a shortcut.
OK.
Thank you.
So it should look like that?
I don't know.
I think I've botched
it, so you're
going to do it right
on the homework.
Let me just-- yeah, good.
This is what it
should look like.
You do need the equals there.
It's because I drew the graph
backwards in the first place.
Anyway, presto change-o.
Going through that
kind of manipulation,
what we eventually
come up with is
something that looks like this.
And I apologize for botching it.
And coming around,
this is tied to this
and this is tied to that.
All right.
And I asked you to imagine
that if I-- what I did
was since I can draw
the Hadamard transform--
either way, I drew
it the wrong way.
And therefore, I wasn't going
to get what I intended to get,
which is this.
But it's done
correctly in Figure 10.
And the types of reductions
that I explained to you
are the types of reduction
that's necessarily
to get from Figure 10A to 10B.
Please do try this at home.
Now, so I claim that this
is a realization of the 8,
4, 4 code.
And you can verify that
either by putting--
you'll find there are four
free internal variables here
and you can either set them
to 1 or you can try this trick
that I discussed
before, I think.
That we can regard these
as an information set.
And by fixing y0,
y1, y2, and y4,
you can trace your
way through the graph
and find out that y3, y5,
y6, and y7 are determined.
Again, do try this at home.
So you can convince
yourself that this
is a graph for 6-- that has
16 possible solutions for all
the internal and
external variables.
16 possible trajectories
that are valid that
satisfy all the
internal constraints.
And that the external
8 tuples that
are parts of these trajectories
are the 8 tuples of the 8,
4, 4 code.
I just assert that now.
Please verify it.
All right, so now
let's step back
and take a look at
this realization.
I believe it's the simplest
representation of the 8, 4,
4 codes if you account the
complexity of the constraints
and of the variables.
Notice that all the internal
variables, the states
if you like, they're all binary.
So it's a two-state
representation
if we want to use that language,
that all the constraints are
simple, either 3, 2, 2
or 3, 1, 3 constraints.
We count that as the branch
complexity in effect.
This isn't a
trellis, but this is
what's analogous to
the branch complexity
as we'll see when we get to
the sum product algorithm.
The complexity is
proportional to the number
of code words in each
of these constraints.
So there are either
2 or 4 code words.
It's a very simple realization.
And there are only 12
of these constraints.
On the other hand, it does have
cycles, like this cycle here.
When we get to the
sum product algorithm,
we'll see that there's
a fundamental difference
between decoding on a graph
with cycles and a graph
without cycles.
Without cycles, we get an
exact decoding algorithm.
It does maximum
likelihood decoding,
like the Viterbi algorithm.
Or actually, a posteriori
probability decoding.
And in any case, it gives us
the optimum, in some sense.
When we decode on a
graph with cycles,
we get some degradation
from the optimum.
Sae-Young Chung tried
decoding with this.
And as I remember, it was a few
tenths of [? db ?] sub-optimum.
It wasn't bad.
But it wasn't optimum either.
So that's the trade-off we make.
Suppose we want to make this
into a cycle-free graph.
We can probably do
that by agglomeration.
Let me suggest the
following agglomeration.
Let's make all of
this-- let's suppress
that cycle into one big block.
Let's suppress this
cycle into one big block.
So we're going to consider
this one overall constraint.
What is that constraint?
We have two outputs.
Or I'm sorry, two
variables over here.
We have four
So it's going to be
some code of length 6.
And from the fact that you have
three inputs coming in here,
you might guess it's going to
be a 6, 3 code, which it is.
So if we do that,
we simply get 6, 3.
And similarly, a 6, 3
constraint down here.
There are 8 possible
valid behaviors
just for this constraint.
And again, since everything
is self-dual here,
it's going to be 6, 3.
So let me, again, assert that.
Does anybody recognize
what this realization is?
Would it help if I
drew it like this?
This is four variables,
four variables.
Anybody?
Come on, you've
seen this before.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
This is a realization
of a different style.
This is now a
cycle-free realization,
as you can easily see either
from this or from-- well,
it's cycle-free now.
Sorry, I should
do one more thing.
I should make this into
a quaternary variable.
So this will be 2.
It's basically u5,
u6 in this notation.
Without doing that,
there's still a cycle.
This little cycle going back and
forth there as we said before.
So somebody I heard say it.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Trellis.
PROFESSOR: Trellis.
It's our two-section
trellis realization
of the 8, 4, 4 code
where we divide a code
word into two
sections of length 4.
And simply, this is the
trellis at the first half.
Eight possible lines,
each one containing
two parallel transitions.
Sorry.
Four lines each containing
two parallel transitions
going to one of eight states.
And that's what the
actual trellis looks like.
So this is, indeed, cycle-free.
What's the difference
between this realization
and the other one?
Well, first of all,
we've got four states
in this cycle-free realization
and we've got-- certainly,
a much larger
constraint code here,
which will turn into complexity,
computational complexity,
when we go to decoding.
Now, we've got a
branch complexity of 8.
Whereas, we never had
anything larger than 4
in the zero sum constraints
of the previous diagram.
So in that sense, this
is more complicated.
Its state complexity,
its branch complexity
is higher than the
cycle-free one that we did.
Than the one with cycles,
but it's cycle-free.
You remember also
we did this one.
We have both of
these going down here
and we consider them each
to be a binary variable,
then we get our
tail-biting realization,
which is only two states.
But it now has a cycle.
And if we're going
to go to cycles,
I would go all the
way to that other one.
But maybe not.
If you decode this
tail-biting realization,
maybe its performance
is a little bit better
because it more
faithfully represents
what's going on inside the
circuit than the other one.
How many different
ways have we had
of realizing the
8, 4, 4 code now?
We've had at least half a
dozen, maybe more than that.
And this is all to
illustrate the various styles
that we have.
We've now had at least
one of each style.
And now we have one
of Hadamard transform.
Or, as I'm going to call it,
we have a reduced Hadamard
transform, the one with only
the 12 simple constraints in it.
Or, we also have the
agglomerated Hadamard
transform, which gets
us to cycle-free.
This has cycles.
But this is simple and this
is, at least, more complex.
So there's a trade.
What do you want?
OK.
Just one more side
comment on the subject.
For exercise 2, which
I didn't assign,
shows that in general
an agglomerated Hadamard
transform realization
of a Reed-Muller code,
you can always get one
that looks like this.
Let's see.
Which is sort of a four-section
realization where each of these
has length 2 to the m minus 2.
This is like the
four-section realization
of the Reed-Muller code.
Each of these
state variables has
dimension which meets
the cut-set bound.
And the cut-set
bound for a cut that
divides the trellis into one
quarter and three quarters
or one half and one half.
You remember all
of these dimensions
were the same as
simply the state
dimension of a
four-section trellis.
And I hope you remember that
the state dimensions were
the same at all four boundaries.
So we always get
the same dimension
for each of these, the same
as in a four-section trellis.
And we get the minimal
trellis complexity here.
So this is going to
turn out to be length
equals 3s and k equals
t, where t is the branch
complexity, the minimal
branch complexity
parameter for a
trellis that we had
in a table back in Chapter 6.
So this actually turns out
to be a nice-- the nicest
I know-- cycle-free realization
of a Reed-Muller code.
For instance, for a 32,
16, 8 code these dimensions
are 18, 9, 18, 9.
These are all 6.
It's a 64-state
realization with 8 symbols
at each of these points.
And each of these
is a 14, 7 code.
Is this fundamentally simpler
than a four-section trellis
realization of the
32, 16, 8 code?
Not really.
The branch complexity
is the same
as it is in the central
sections of this code.
This is very close
to being a-- it
is a four-section
realization if we
draw the four
sections like this.
Except we have to draw a little
additional thing up here,
which is slightly helpful.
So it's sort of a expanded
trellis that looks like this.
OK, so maybe think of that as a
quote, "explanation" for this.
And I give explicit expressions
for s and particularly
for t, which perhaps
you can derive
or perhaps you don't care.
You won't be held
responsible for it, anyway.
You might even remember that
the Golay code, the 24, 12,
8 realization, which
looked very much like this
but contained only three
sections, each of length 8
and a single 18, 9
constraint in the middle.
These were all 6.
Maybe you remember
that, maybe you don't.
But that's a realization
of the Golay code.
And it shows that these two
codes are very close cousins.
There are many ways of
showing that they're
very close cousins.
They are.
OK, so now I'm just going
off into side comments.
You obviously won't
be held responsible
for any of the side comments.
But I hope they give you
something of a flavor
for how the subject
can be developed.
OK, that's the
end of Chapter 11.
There is an appendix
in Chapter 11
that talks about other
flavors of graphs.
Factor graphs is a more
embracing philosophically,
conceptually notion where each
of the constraints, instead
of representing codes represents
the factors, local factors,
some global function
factors into a product
of local functions.
The local functions are
represented by constraints.
It's a nice way of
looking at things.
It's not strictly
necessary for this course,
so I haven't gone into it.
But most of the literature now
is in terms of factor graphs.
In other fields, we
have related topics,
like Markov graphs or
Markov random fields.
And slight
differences in choices
have been made in these areas.
Here, you see we're
putting all the variables
on the edges and the
constraints as nodes in a graph.
And that's the
normal graph style.
In Markov graphs,
they make exactly
the opposite convention.
They make the variables into
nodes, which is probably
what most people would
do if they sat down
to start doing a graphical
model of something.
And they make the
constraints into edges.
But there are several
problems with that.
One is that if you have a
constraint of larger degree
than 2, then you really
need a hyper-edge,
which is represented
by a clique.
And cliques sometimes
introduce artifacts
that you don't really want.
So I think it's actually
an inferior style,
but it's a very popular
style in some fields.
Physics, particularly, for
indicating dependencies.
All of these
graphical models are
methods of indicating
dependencies
and what's related to what.
There's another style.
It's very popular in
statistical inference,
which is called
Bayesian networks.
And this style is
similar to ours
except the graphs are directed.
Everything is a cause
and effect relationship.
So you have one variable
that causes another variable.
We've generally stayed away
from cause and effect here.
We've used the behavioral
style, undirected graph.
But Bayesian networks
have been hugely popular
in statistical inference.
And so the appendix is just
to explain the relationship
between these various styles.
And obviously, you can
work with any of them.
It's a matter of preference.
OK, any other questions
about Chapter 11?
This was the basic introduction
to codes on graphs.
Chapter 11 is, what
are codes on graphs?
Chapter 12 is, how do we
decode codes on graphs?
Which is the sum
product algorithm.
So we'll move into that now.
And then Chapter
13, we'll actually
talk about classes of
capacity-approaching codes.
So these three
chapters certainly
form a closely related set that
should all be read together.
OK, what are the basic facts
about sum product algorithm?
I'm going to describe it as a
method of doing A Posteriori
Probability decoding,
APP decoding, initially
on cycle-free graphs.
I'll define-- what do I mean
by a posteriori probability
decoding?
Then, we'll develop the
algorithm for cycle-free graphs
where the theory is
kind of complete.
There are various theorems
that you can easily
prove about the performance
of the algorithm here.
The algorithm completes in
a finite amount of time.
Basically, equal
the amount of time
it takes to get from
one side of the graph
to the other, which in
graph theory language
is called the
diameter of the graph.
And it does exact a posteriori
probability decoding.
So if that's actually
what you want to do,
this is a good way of doing it.
If you do this on a trellis
for instance, it's the, by now,
well-known BCJR algorithm,
for Bahl, Cocke, Jelinek,
and Raviv, who published
this algorithm back in 1973.
Probably known in other
fields before that.
Actually, you can sort of
find it in Gallagher's thesis.
You can certainly find the
sum product algorithm there.
Anyway, the BCJR
algorithm is now
widely used as a component
of these decoding algorithms
for turbo codes, in particular,
and capacity-approaching codes
in general because it's an
exact way of decoding a trellis.
And probably fast.
Although, we'll find it's
more complex than the Viterbi
algorithm.
So if you are just interested
in decoding a trellis,
you would probably use
the Viterbi algorithm.
But you use the BCJR
algorithm when you actually
want to compute the a
posteriori probabilities.
And that's what
you want when it's
part of a larger algorithm.
So we'll do all the development
on cycle-free graph.
Where we really,
eventually, want to use
it is on graphs with cycles.
And there are
hardly any theorems.
In this case, you find yourself
going around the cycles.
So there are all kinds
of new questions.
How do you start?
When do you stop?
What are its
convergence properties?
It becomes an iterative
and approximate algorithm.
For instance, when I said that
decoding of that simple, little
reduced Hadamard transform
realization for the 8, 4,
4 code, which had
cycles in it, I
said it was a couple of tenths
of [? db ?] sub-optimum.
That was obtained by
running this algorithm
on that little graph with
cycles until it seemed
to have converged to something
and plotting its performance.
And it's not quite as
good as the performance
would be on a cycle-free
graph like this one.
All right, so you give up
something in performance.
And you give up-- it
becomes an algorithm
that runs indefinitely.
And you'd have to figure
out some stopping criterion
and so forth.
All together, it's much
more, what are we doing here?
We can't really say
with any precision what
we're doing here in most cases.
Although, in Chapter 13, I'll
give some cases where we can
say quite precisely
what it's doing.
But it becomes much
harder to analyze.
But in coding, this is
actually what you want to do.
This is what works.
Just try it on a graph with
cycles and hope for the best.
And because we design
our own graphs in coding,
we can design them so that
the algorithm works very well.
Basically, we want
to design them
to have cycles, but extremely
large cycles, large girth.
And then the algorithm
tends not to get confused
and to be near optimal.
Because it takes a long
time for information
to propagate around
the cycle and it's
pretty attenuated
when it comes back in.
Whereas, with the short
cycles that you saw here,
that's not good.
And in many of
these other fields,
like physics for instance,
image processing,
you're dealing with graphs
that look like grids.
Something like that.
You have lots and
lots of short cycles.
And then just applying
the sum product algorithm
to a graph that
looks like that won't
work well at all
because you have
these little, short cycles.
So if you can design
your own graph,
this is a good thing to do.
OK, so let's get into it.
First of all, let
me describe what
I mean by a posteriori
probability decoding.
This means simply that
for every variable,
both internal variables
and external variables,
we want to compute the
probability of that variable.
Let's call it probability that
some external variable y, k
takes on some
particular value y, k
given the entire
received sequence.
OK, so you can think in
terms of the 8, 4, 4 code.
We're going to take this code.
We're going to transmit it over
some kind of a noisy channel.
We're going to get
a received sequence.
And from that, we want to
figure out the probability
that any particular input
bit is equal to a 0 or a 1.
That might be more precisely
what we're going to do.
So we really want
to develop a vector
consisting of the values of
this a posteriori probability
for all possible
values of the variable.
This is sometimes
called a message.
But this is what we're
going to try to compute.
If we're actually
decoding a code
and we get the a
posteriori probabilities
for all these variables,
then at the end of the day,
what do we want to do?
We want to make hard
decisions on each of these
and decide what was sent.
It's quite easy to show.
Actually, I'm not sure
I do this in the notes.
That a posteriori
probability decoding
is what you want
to do to minimize
the probability of bit error.
What's the probability
of bit error?
It's the probability that y is
not what you guessed it was.
In other words, it's 1 minus
the max of all of these.
You would choose the max.
The probability of it
actually being the max
is given by that a
posteriori probability.
And 1 minus that
is the probability
that it's anything else.
And that's the bit
error probability.
So doing maximum a posteriori
probability decoding
on a bit-wise basis is the way
of minimizing the bit error
probability.
Now, that isn't
actually what we've
been doing in the
Viterbi algorithm,
for instance, or in
general in our decoding.
We've said, we want to minimize
the probability of decoding
any code word on
a sequence basis.
We want to minimize the
probability of error
in decoding the whole sequence.
So these are not
exactly the same thing.
In fact, if you do
max APP decoding,
you may not even
get a code word.
You'll make individual
decisions on each of these bits,
and that may not
actually be a code word.
There's nothing that
requires it to be.
Usually, it is.
Usually, there's no difference.
These algorithms tend to--
at least in relatively good
signal noise, reach
ratio situations.
They tend to both
give the same answer.
And the probability of
bit error or word error
is not markedly
different whichever one
you use as a practical matter.
But it's certainly
possible in principle
that since maximum likelihood
sequence decoding gives you
the lowest word
error probability,
maximum APP bit-wise
decoding has
got to give you a higher
word error probability.
So in any particular
situation, you've
got to decide which is
more important to you,
minimizing the bit
error probability
or minimizing the probability
of any error in the whole block.
Actually, generally, the
latter is what you prefer.
That governs your minimum
time between decoding
errors and things like that.
So that's a general discussion
of what APP decoding is.
Why do we want it here?
Because when we get to
capacity-approaching codes,
we're going to talk
about big codes that
are made up of smaller codes.
The great thing about this
graphical realization-- this
is realization of
linear systems.
You realize a big system
by putting together blocks
representing little systems.
That's a good way
of designing things
for all kinds of reasons.
It's going to be
the way we design
capacity-approaching codes.
And we're going
to want a decoding
algorithm for a
part of a system.
Say, this 6, 3 part,
or say something else.
Say this whole thing is
a part of the system.
This whole thing is just 8, 4.
That yields soft probabilistic
information in the output
that we can then feed
into decoding algorithms
for other parts of the system.
So we won't want to
make hard decisions.
We'll want to feed the whole
message, the whole vector
of a posteriori
probabilities from one--
a partially decoded
part of the system.
We'll feed that into some other
part and then go decode that.
For instance, in
turbo codes we'll
decode-- we'll make it up out
of several convolutional codes.
There will be several trellises.
We'll do BCJR decoding
of one trellis.
That will give us a bunch of
a posteriori probabilities
about the bits that are
involved in that trellis,
then we'll pass them back
to some other trellis
decoder that's
decoding-- apparently,
a different trellis,
but involving
some of the same bits.
So maybe I shouldn't go on too
long with these generalities,
but that's why APP
decoding is going
to be a good thing for us to do.
And it's not because
ultimately we
want to do APP decoding
of a single code.
It's because we want
the soft decisions
to feed into other decoding.
All right.
How do we compute this?
Probability that
yk equals yk given
r is going to be a basic
probability theory.
It's just the sum over
all, let's say, code words
in which yk equals yk of the
probability of those code
words.
So sum over all y.
I'm just making
up notation here.
In our code, we're
going to have some code
words in the code
that have yk equals 0
and some code words
that have yk equals 1.
So we'll divide the code
words into two sets,
the ones that are
compatible with yk equals 0
and the ones that are
compatible with yk equals 1.
The a posteriori
probability of yk
equals yk is simply the sum of
the a posteriori probabilities
that we get of any
of those code words.
I don't have to make
proportional sign there.
But by Bayes' law, each of
these-- Bayes' p of y given r
is proportional to.
Here's a sign that
a lot of people use.
I'm not completely
comfortable with it yet,
but that means proportional to.
Prop 2 in [INAUDIBLE].
Probability of r given y.
In other words, the a posteriori
probability of a code word
is proportional to the
probability of r given y.
Why?
Because by Bayes', it's actually
equal to that times probability
of y over probability of r.
But this is the same
for all of them.
If the code words
are all equiprobable,
these are the same
for all of them.
So it's just proportional
to the likelihood
of getting r given
that you transmitted y.
I'm sure you've seen
this many times before,
so I won't do in detail.
So this is proportional
to the same sum.
y in this code word,
where y-- a portion
of the code where yk equals y.
p of r given y.
But that's easy.
I'm assuming that I have
a memoryless channel here.
That's been implicit
throughout this course,
like the Additive White Gaussian
Noise channel or the Binary
Symmetric channel.
So this just breaks up into
a component-wise product.
This is just the product
of p of-- over the k.
p of rk given yk.
And because yk has the same--
I should say k prime here.
Sorry, that's very confusing.
So this is over all k prime.
But I can break this up.
One of these terms
is going to be k.
For that, yk is fixed at little
yk, at this particular value.
So I can write this in turn
as this for k prime not equal
to k.
And then I get a common term
which is p of rk given yk.
OK, so this is the expression
that I want to compute.
Two comments.
When I say "sum
product," it's really
because this is just a
sum of products here.
We see we want to
compute this actually
rather nasty sum of products.
We're looking for
an efficient way
of computing the
sum of products.
And we're going to
show how this could
be computed by tracing
through the graph.
That's one comment.
The second comment is that in
the literature, particularly
in the turbo code
literature, this has a name.
This part, the direct
likelihood of the symbol given
what you received
corresponding to that symbol,
is called the intrinsic
information about y, k.
And this part, which has
to do with, basically,
the likelihood of yk given
all the other yk prime,
for k prime not
equal to k, is called
the extrinsic information.
We basically take
these two parts,
which we can compute separately,
and we multiply them together.
And we get the
overall probability.
So the probability consists
of a part due to rk
and a part due to all
those other rk prime,
which we're going to compute
by going through the graph.
And I just introduced
this language
because if you
read papers, you're
going to see this
throughout the literature.
OK.
Let me start moving back.
I never used this.
Well, let me introduce
one more thing.
So we want to compute
all these messages.
In particular, we want to
compute the probability of yk
equals yk given r.
This part here is really the
r on k prime not equal to k.
Terrible notation.
The other r's.
So that'll be a message.
We also want to
compute similar things
for all the internal variables,
which we have sometimes
called state variables.
And it breaks up
in the same way.
And I won't take the trouble
to write out the expression.
But again, now we
really want to go over
all configurations which
have a particular state
variable in them.
So we're really going
over all behaviors.
And we can compute
probabilities this way.
I won't belabor that right now.
So we want messages, really,
indicating the likelihood
of each of the
external variables
and each of the
internal variables.
The whole set of
possible likelihoods,
the APP vector, the message,
for both the symbol variables
and the state variables.
And that's what the
sum product algorithm
is going to do for us.
OK.
So the sum product
algorithm is based
on-- I discuss it three parts.
One is the past future
decomposition of the code.
Another is the actual
sum product update rule,
which is based on
another decomposition.
And finally, we need
an overall schedule.
OK, so let me
discuss this first.
Let's take a particular
state variable.
I only mean internal variable.
And here it is.
Somewhere in our big
graph, it's an edge.
Our big graph is cycle-free.
So what's the special property
of edges in cycle-free graphs?
Every edge is a cut-set.
So if I take this edge, it
divides the whole graph--
we've done this before--
into two parts, which
we can call past and future.
And if we were to
take out this edge,
it would disconnect the
graph from these two parts.
So there's no other connections
between the past and the future
because the graph is cycle-free.
And there's some set of
past observed variables, rp,
and there's some set of
future observe variables, rf.
So before, I called
this yp and yf.
These are the received
observations corresponding
to all the past variables,
the received observations
corresponding to all
the future variables.
And the past future
decomposition
is basically like this here.
Let me write it out.
It basically says that the
probability of-- that state
variable has a
particular value given
r is proportional
to the probability
that the state variable has
a particular value given r--
that part-- times the
probability that it has
a particular value based
on the future part.
And that we can simply--
when we take the vector,
we can simply multiply
the two components
that both have a
common value sk and we
get the overall a posteriori
probability that this state
variable has a particular value.
Now, I'm sure there is a-- OK.
In the notes, I go through
a little development
to show this.
The development is, first
of all, based on the fact
that if I ask-- now in the
corresponding expression here,
I want to have
the sum over all y
and s such that the behaviot--
I'm going to just lose myself
in notation here.
We only have a few minutes left.
This is basically going
to be over a code that's
consistent with the state
having this particular variable.
But when I cut this
code up like this,
the overall code of
all configurations
that are consistent with a
certain state variable sk
is going to divide up
into a Cartesian product
of the past part
of the code that's
consistent with sk across the
future part of the code that's
consistent with sk.
And this was
precisely the argument
we went through when we
developed the cut-set bound.
That given sk, we
can take any past
that's consistent with
sk and any future that's
consistent with sk
and map them together.
And in effect, fixing the state
does disconnect the graph.
And this is the
basic Markov property
that we used to develop
the cut-set bound.
Really, just depending
on that again.
Plus the basic Cartesian
product, lemma,
which is that if I have a
sum over a Cartesian product,
x cross of f of x g of y, what's
a fast way of computing that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is trivial.
But in fact, that's what we
do in many fast algorithms.
It's just the sum over
the x of the f part,
the sum over y of the g part.
And you multiply
those two together.
Just think of x and y being
on some rectangular array.
Here, we compute
all the products
corresponding to every
combination of x and y
individually.
Here, we first take
the sum of all those,
the sum all those.
We multiply them times
the sum of-- in this way.
And we will get exactly the same
terms if we multiply them out.
And so this is just a fast
way of computing this.
And that's really what we're
doing when we divide this up
in this way.
I think I'm incapable
of explaining that
any more clearly right now And
we're at the end of our time,
anyway.
So we do want to
not do problem 8.3.
You have only one problem due
on Wednesday, which is 8.1.
It will probably take
you a while, anyway.
We didn't get to
the BCJR algorithm.
We'll take this up again
and complete the sum product
algorithm next time.
See you Wednesday.